The European Parliament,
with five hundred and four votes,
passed a resolution according to which Armenia will be supported and it is proposed
to consider the possibility of granting Armenia the status
of candidate for membership in the e.
In addition,
the resolution stressed the following points,
recognizes that the influence of the Russian federation
on the Armenian economy remains high,
calls on Armenia to be vigilant about 1 possible circumvention of eye sanctions
in the country and fully aware of the level and diversity of threats that the Russian
federation may attempt to use against Armenia in order to punish it for its independent
political and strategic choices Hi Armenia's decision to suspend its participation
in the otsc after its failure to assist Armenia in the fight against military aggression
Supports Armenia's official request to Russia to
withdraw the FSB border guards from D.
R.
Van Souly International Airport.
Nickle must be prepared to impose sanctions against any
natural or legal person who threatens the sovereignty,
independence and territorial integrity of Armenia.